si la toux
et ce huit ans
machenaud
si avec un optimisme mesuré pour vous
présenter combien de l'équipage pour le
championnat français vichy alors vichy
nous présenteront six équipages à huit
juniors 1 4 sans barreur cas les deux
coupes kdc les trois équipages de
garçons et chez les filles un double
juniors filles et deux skiffs minimes
les six équipes vous avez bon espoir
pour plusieurs médailles c'est à dire
qu'on espère avoir les meilleurs
résultats possibles principalement mai
chance 3 4 ou lait pas citer mois
non je préfère faut tenir les résultats
le dimanche soir
ce quatre sans barreur que vous voyez a
de bonnes chances de bien figurer
dimanche
mais les espoirs du smv sont surtout
portés par un de deux courts et juniors
filles royal avec la championne de
france sylvie la mer c'est la mer 18 ans
puis côtes qui sera dix sept ans s'est
vite eu et de l'aviron depuis combien de
temps
déjà tu en fait pourquoi ce que je
trouve ça très joli c'est pas trop
exigeants comme sport envoûte deux ans
tu vas tu championne de france a su
scolaire et qui va au championnat de
france dimanche pas trop fatigué bien
préparé je suis à peu près quelle place
la première tant qu'à faire
alors qu'est ce que ça fait de ramener
avec une championne de france scolaire
c'est très bien j'ai concentré n'est
assez durement ensemble ça fait six mois
un peu vrai un entraînement qui se fait
à cadence peu près combien
d'entraînement par semaine pour le
moment
on va presque tous les jours la semaine
et 10 10 km à 15 km environ face à ces
dures mais comme on aime ça j'avais
encore
vous compterez faire de l'aviron pendant
combien de temps encore chitral plus
longtemps possible tant que je pourrai